Stargate might have found its production
company
could be bad robot
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so a couple of weeks ago on a live
stream we actually joked that oh God
what if Bad Robot actually took on the
production
running of a new Stargate series because
it would seem that that's currently
what's holding up Stargate we've been
talking a lot about them for having to
find a showrunner but actually Amazon
don't make TV shows themselves and well
MGM don't either really they actually
work in partnership with production
companies who make the TV shows for them
so Amazon need to find that company
it would seem according to a source I've
been speaking to the Bad Robot of
already pitched to MGM about possibly
taking on the role so before I tell you
actually about the pitch and roughly
what the story idea is let me just tell
you quickly about the source
right so as you know if you're a regular
side tracker there's a few people I used
to speak to one in particular that used
to work at MGM he now works for another
firm through his other job he came into
contact with this person this person is
somebody that does computer generated
imagery they're a very technical person
and they actually worked on the pitch
for Bad Robot they don't work for Bad
Robot they work for a company that Bad
Robot used to create the imagery and the
animation etc for the pitch meeting
so this person no longer works for that
company they work for a different agency
it's quite common that type of role they
do quite sure to Consulting sort of
contract so they were more than happy to
talk about it to my source he was more
than happy to share it with me so when
did this pitch meeting happen according
to my source the pitch meeting happened
in September this year apparently MGM
and Amazon have been putting it out
there since as early as February to
production companies suggesting that if
any of them would like to come forward
to the pitch that they would be
interested to discuss it and apparently
as early as February Bad Robot expressed
an interest so they've come forward and
in September as I say they pitched a
suggestion for what they would do with
the franchise if you haven't subscribed
already please do and like and share the
video wherever the hell you want also if
you enjoy the content and you want to
support the Channel please hit the join
button also we have our sister Channel
Sidetrack sites where we do lots of
little best bits from the lives and lots
of other Fun City little videos so
please go and subscribe to sites so what
do I think about Bad Robot taking on the
Stargate franchise if that's what
happens well my instinct I gotta admit
is dear God no please no please don't
but that's a knee-jerk reaction to the
Star Trek movies
which even though I quite like them as
films they're not Star Trek it's a ninja
reaction to the couple of Star Wars
movies Bad Robot did they weren't good
it's a ninja reaction to lens flares and
things like that
but actually if you look at the sort of
projects Banner I've done over the years
they've done some really good television
shows in it and a couple of good movies
both of the mission impossible films
that they did were pretty good back in
the day I loved Fringe I was never a big
fan of lost it started brilliant I know
it was massively loved but it really
ended weekly they did a series called
Almost Human which got canceled halfway
through the first series with Carl Urban
and which was brilliant I was gutted
that show got canceled and obviously
Westworld even though for me Series 2 3
went great the first series was
absolutely brilliant they are capable of
making really good movies and really
good TV shows in lots of ways they're an
obvious choice for MGM because they've
got the experience to do both and if MGM
and Amazon generally want to bring
Stargate back and turn it into not just
a TV show but actual franchise with
movies and television series Bad Robot
in lots of ways is a sensible company to
choose
should also be said that it's not the
first time Bad Robot has been linked to
Stargate back in 2014 2015 MGM did try
to reboot a hard reboot of the franchise
they wanted to create a Trilogy of
movies initially Roland Emerick was
signed up to do this that deal fell
through quite quickly and it was very
heavily rumored the Bad Robot we're
going to step in MGM mainly because of
financial reasons decided not to go
ahead with the project but
maybe bad robots are about to get a
second crack of the whip it's also maybe
good timing for Bad Robot because you
know they've done Star Wars they've done
Star Trek it doesn't look like Star Trek
4 is going to happen they don't have
really a big franchise in their Arsenal
at the moment
they've got a couple of big TV shows
coming up with Warner Brothers but
actually Sarah Aubry who's the head of
original content to HBO in a recent
interview with um variety magazine did
actually say Bad Robot had pitched a
couple of big franchise projects to them
that they declined they don't really
have any big franchise movies coming up
as I say Star Trek 4 is almost certainly
not going to happen at this point and
really they're not going to get another
Star Wars film looking at their upcoming
projects really the biggest thing I can
see is that they're planning to do a
Speed Racer TV show with Warner Brothers
but even that to be honest is not a sure
thing
so what do I think about this news
really
I have to like unplug my brain here a
little bit and because my heart says
please no please don't do this please
keep JJ Abrams the hell away from my TV
show I love Stargate it's my favorite
show ever made I don't particularly like
what JJ Abrams did with Star Trek and if
he does that to Stargate oh that would
be bad
I think particularly with Star Trek Bad
Robot change things for the sake of it
and for me even though I love the films
I thought they were actually really good
they're not Star Trek
now if he brought back a new TV show
even if it was good even if I enjoyed it
if he faffed around with things and
changed things just for the sake of it
like he did with Star Trek it won't be
Stargate
and I'm not sure I could really go
through that again
so I want respect I hope these rumors
aren't true but if I just go with my
head and I honestly just look at the
sort of projects Bad Robot has done over
the years they have done some TV shows
and movies that I absolutely love
so am I willing to give another benefit
of the doubt
Maybe
another thing to think about though is
that this pitch apparently happened in
September what I'm being told is a
decision is going to be made or that we
will know about a decision roughly
around the new year now is that because
they have decided to go a Bad Robot is
that because other production companies
are also pitching and MGM are then going
to make a decision at the end of it
I'm not sure but I'd have thought if it
was a successful pitch wouldn't we know
now I have to say that the person that's
given me this information has no clue
how the pitch went they were not
involved in that they were involved in
creating some of the animation etc for
the pitch so they simply don't know
but what they do know is roughly what
Bad Robot are intending to do with
Stargate now as I've told you before
apparently
corcospi and Mark Fergus are working
hard to create a Bible for whichever
production company then takes on the
Stargate mantle they're developing a
do's and don'ts for the TV series that
then Amazon will sign off on and the new
production company under its license to
create the show will be actually
contractually obliged to follow where
the hawk Coast being Mark Fergus will
then get involved in producing the new
TV show we just don't know but I am
reassured that Amazon are actually going
through this process to make sure that
whatever production company they're
licensed to don't mess with Canon more
than they're willing to let them at
least but what was the pitch and what
were they intending to do with the story
well this is where I am actually very
concerned because according to the
source they are planning to do sort of a
semi-hard reboot they wanted to do sort
of at least to begin with a time travel
movie and followed Series where ra never
actually came to Earth the Stargate was
found but no one ever actually figured
out how to work it so none of what we've
seen in Stargate sg1 even the movie
originally happened it pitched to do a
movie first and then a 10 episode
streaming series that would cover this
storyline and then potentially another
movie which would then go into the
restoring of the timeline I really don't
know how I feel about that I hate timing
whiny episodes and I hate them messing
with Canon and I hate it when they use
time travel as an excuse or a cheat code
to get around missing the Canon like
they did for Star Trek but apparently a
big part of the pitch was that they
would return back to Canon at the end of
possibly the second movie depending I
imagine that depends on how the series
goes now as I say I don't know how
Amazon took that pitch I don't know if
Amazon could even go back and say well
that picture is great but we'd like you
to go in a slightly different direction
and Pitch again I don't know we'll have
to find out but if this is true at least
it is again more evidence that Amazon is
serious about Stargate and are working
towards a new series A lot of people are
getting nervous I'm getting nervous that
maybe Amazon aren't serious about
bringing back Stargate but one thing we
have to hold on to and that we have to
remember is that Amazon love money they
love the teaching and at the end of the
day Stargate is one of the biggest IPS
that MGM own at one point it was only
second to bond for its financial worth
to MGM and let's be honest that is a big
incentive for Amazon I'm absolutely
certain Stargate is going to be back
with us very very soon
but what do you think what do you think
about this news what do you think about
the very vague pitch idea that seems to
have been sent over please get into the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit the Bell
notification only helps us out and as
always if you enjoy the content and you
want to support the channel consider
hitting the join button and becoming a
fully flooded side Trekker as always
please stay safe I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]